just last night the White House Director
of National Intelligence finally
released its Declassified report on the
origins of covid-19 but that report
mainly details how agencies are divided
about whether it started in a lab or in
nature it says quote
variations in intelligence in the
community analytic views on the origins
of covid-19 pandemic largely stemmed
from differences in how agencies weigh
intelligence reporting and scientific
Publications and intelligence and
scientific gaps all agencies continue to
assess
they're both a natural and laboratory
Associated origin remain plausible
hypotheses to explain the first human
infection here to help make sense of
this Ohio Congressman Brad wenstrip
chairman of the house select
subcommittee on the covid pandemic Mr
chairman thank you so much for being
here so we're still are we still doing
this run around oh it could have been
anything when common sense and a lot of
evidence has pointed to exactly where it
came from
yeah so let's let's start with the
comment that you just had up there that
came from the report that which led me
to ask on intelligence committee a place
where I've been studying this for the
last three years is who did you actually
talk to because that matters and I'm
digging down into that right now because
if you're only talking to people that
have a motive to say that this came from
nature you're going to get a variety of
opinions and I will tell you that what I
have seen so far is the doe and the FBI
have done the most work dealing with the
experts that would have the most ability
to make a conclusion and especially one
that would lean towards it coming from
the lab but we've you know this report
is is very disturbing from the
standpoint that unanimously in the house
and President Biden signed it we sought
to declassify all the intelligence that
they would have uh pertaining to the
Wuhan Institute of virology and origins
of covet and now they present this and
say there's a classified Annex the whole
idea was to declassify and I've been
looking at this for three years and even
even two three years ago we realized
China has the capability as do we to
create a chimera to create a gain a
function type of virus we've also
discovered things that the government
accountability office has revealed that
U.S dollars were going to China for
Coronavirus research but what the thing
what the report did show is that there
were biosafety deficiencies in China uh
with training and with policies but
there are also things that we have
looked at as there were problems within
the facilities themselves and that uh
we'll uh
it's a genetically engineered
coronaviruses that's important and that
scientists fell ill in 2019. now one of
the things they say in the report is
that not all of their symptoms were
consistent with covet 19. well I can
tell you as a physician watching this
from the beginning every person has been
different some people didn't even know
they had coveted so I don't think that
that should even be mentioned in there
but if they had Cova type symptoms
that's enough but also their executive
summary at the very beginning did point
out that we were only looking at the
Wuhan Institute of virology but keep in
mind that their military component is
right in Wuhan also and they look at
bioweapons and coronaviruses it's called
the fifth Institute and after the
pandemic the military actually took over
the Wuhan Institute of virology so I
think it's very a very deficient report
yeah you know I don't think I need a
fancy report to figure out that they
disappeared a bunch of uh whistleblowers
Chinese scientists very early on were
disappeared red flag right there then we
had the emails from Anthony fauci and
and his buddy sort of covering up so we
exposed that as well
um and now I mean we're going to talk to
you about these payments that were made
to the Biden family but I mean it seems
to me like you know they killed seven
million people with covid and if it came
out that China was indeed not just
responsible for it for whether
nefariously or by accident with the lab
leak that they should be held
accountable and somehow this report gets
them off the hook and at the same time
the Biden family is getting tens of
millions of dollars from the Chinese
sounds like a pretty cheap way to keep
the cover on this for China
well I think you're connecting the dots
pretty well there Rachel but you know
more disturbing is what was actually
going on in this country uh since covet
began and especially as we're trying to
find the origins you know we've done
transcribed interviews on all the
authors of what was called proximal
Origins which came out in in early 2020
stating that this came from nature well
let's back this up a little bit at the
end of February Christian Anderson
emails Dr fauci and says this thing
looks engineered Christian Anderson is
one of the authors of proximal Origins
so he goes from saying it looks
engineered to emphatically saying it
came from nature with other authors but
what we found from internal documents is
that he also had conversations with
other people and in those conversations
he said that Dr fauci prompted the
writing of proximal Origins and he also
said that his job was to focus on this
disproving lamply Theory you know what
what is going on with that why should
that be and I will tell you we found out
Dr Anderson had some internal
Communications using uh slack messaging
and that was our first subpoena this
week is to get the the information that
was taking place in his slack messaging
I mean a virus comes out of Wuhan and
there's a virology lab at Wuhan and
we're still debating it yeah and the
military and a military and a military
as the chairman pointed out Brad
wenstrom thank you thank you so much
appreciate your time thank you thank you
you got it I'm Steve Ducey I'm Brian
Kilmeade and I'm Ainsley Earhart and
click here to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis